when we log on to Facebook or search
with Google most of us know that we're
paying for those services not with money
but with our personal data now a new
report from Amnesty International says
that price has become too high to pay
and the two tech giant's are quote a
threat to human rights that report you
see it here is titled surveillance
Giants how the business model of Google
and Facebook threatens human rights it
lays out a case in some 60 pages that
the two companies are now too large to
avoid in our daily lives Facebook has
responded to that report saying it quote
fundamentally disagrees and stating in
part a person's choice to use Facebook's
services and the way we collect receive
or use data is all clearly disclosed and
acknowledged by users and cannot
meaningfully be likened it to the
involuntary and often unlawful
government surveillance joining me now
is the lead author of that study Joe
Westby he's also a researcher on
technology Big Data and human rights for
amnesty tech Joe I mean this is a
massive report we're talking 60 pages I
mean there aren't really any new
revelations here but the conclusions I
find really striking him and it calls
these companies control over our digital
lives one of the defining human rights
challenges of our times why is that
Thanks I think that's right
really the scale of the dominance of
these platforms and the way that
Facebook and Google are profiting from
people's most intimate information
really does pose a systemic threat to
human rights for billions of people
around the world and these companies
rely on harvesting vast amount of data
about everything that we do in the
digital world
and then through the use of
sophisticated algorithmic tools knowing
virtually everything about us and if a
government had done this it would have
been completely intolerable but these
companies are just doing it to sell
and I think people are now waking up to
the fact that this is a serious threat
to our rights and it's time to overhaul
the business model that these companies
rely on how do you think we've gotten to
that point where what you say is
companies doing something we'd never
tolerate from a government how have we
gotten there have we learned that to
happen well that's a great question I
mean I think if you look at the
company's business model when they first
started they were much more privacy
respecting but as they have grown in
size and scale to the point where really
it is impossible to navigate the digital
world without coming under their
corporate surveillance machine and the
companies have been able to gradually
erode our privacy and threaten our
rights and all whole host of ways
without being held fully accountable and
I think you know we're increasingly now
seeing the the symptoms of this deeper
problem pretty much every week you know
just last week there was a Financial
Times investigation about how the
company's dozens of ad tech companies
including of course Google and Facebook
who sit at the heart of this system
we're receiving highly sensitive health
data from health websites including
medical symptoms diagnosis fertility
information that there's that is the
opposite of privacy and is an intrusion
into our private lives now want to take
a look at what else Facebook had to say
to say in response to your report here's
one bit of their response they say our
business model is what allows us to
offer an important service where people
can exercise foundational human rights
to have a voice freedom of expression
and be able to connect freedom of
association and assembly I mean I'm sure
you've also been following the situation
in Iran the internet there was
completely shut down during
anti-government protests many people
there could not use a tool like Facebook
or a tool like whatsapp to communicate
so on the other hand there are some
important pro-democracy features to
these
as well right yes absolutely and we
recognize that in fact that's exactly
the problem the scale of these platforms
they have become the the global public
square that billions of people rely on
to express themselves online to engage
with modern society that's the problem
in order to realize our human rights in
the digital age
we are forced to consent to a system
which is predicated on human rights
abuse and that is an impossible choice
for people to face and that's exactly
why you know governments need to address
the scale and dominance of these
platforms and you know radically
overhaul the business model so that we
can move towards a rights respecting
internet which really you know restores
the promise of the Internet for our
rights and for society of course some
governments have been taking action the
general data protection regulation gdpr
was enacted here in the EU last year
that could be one way to go about it Joe
Westby he's a researcher on technology
Big Data and human rights for Amnesty
International thank you very much thank
you so much